[Music]
do you guys know how
la has been experiencing a lot of like
rolling blackouts
kind of situations have you my oven
reset uh
there was supposed to be like the heat
waves and then um i remember i was
driving
all like it was during the day luckily
everyone stopped
but all the street lights are out do you
guys know why because i don't know heat
it's the heat that's just preventing
i think so everyone's like running there
he sees the children oh so the acs are
maybe using up the energy so i think i
think they want to black things out so
that the energy
won't get depleted oh is it kind of like
why the other international background
like the scene like forest fires are
controlled
yeah like that or like when the when the
cops like slow down the freeway like
they stop the freeway and like to
decompress it or whatever
yeah they're saying the blackouts i
think are from 2pm to 9pm and it's gonna
rotate
cities oh it is because we haven't been
affected yet we haven't yet
has is this a thing happening well
anyway it made me think about the
blackouts because
this story here the la mayor eric
garcetti
he has confirmed that he had authorized
a city to disconnect utility service at
a hollywood hills home
after it had been warned a lot of times
that this was going to happen because
they were hosting
several large parties in flagrant val
violations
too much parties they canceled the power
to uh my roommates gymnastics
they did yes we had because he had too
many parties there well
he just left the business open and it's
like filled with like 50 people every
second oh yeah
why did that make the people go or they
just still just lifted no now
there's even more people because now
he's like promoting it's like fun um so
now they like candles they so at night
they during the day they have had uh
skylights but then at night they bring
in those like
worker lumps yeah they get from home
depot and they run portable speakers
yeah that sounds fun
wait so like what's the logic there with
your roommate you don't give a [ __ ] well
people in
the valley don't really believe in covid
valley i mean obviously they believe in
[ __ ] gains huh
yeah like i got muscles i'm gonna
[ __ ] work
this virus out of me yeah wait a minute
there's a lot of pockets all over
california that they just don't
huntington beach is another one yeah
they don't believe in it and me saying
they don't believe in it
it's not like what people are going to
get mad at me saying that they believe
in it but they just don't care
they don't believe it that's even worse
their their business yeah
that's probably worse than i believe but
it's not that nadeem is believing he's
just
explaining people the existence of these
types of people
well i'm a little nervous because this
is your roommate
and you live with this roommate and now
you're here yeah i mean we're also glad
to eat and stuff
i feel like it's no different kind of
i also don't our house is big so he's
social distancing the whole time in the
house
i go to my room that's it you wear a
mask inside your house and do you make
me feel better
i wear like a emotional mask oh [ __ ]
sometimes i'm like stronger i know right
i'm just like
why didn't you say anything before it's
like and the next article is
that's what jk news hey guys so
we have something here we'll have him
wear it he's the spreader
i'm fine i just traveled to turkey too
by the way did you quarantine your ass
give me the test they make you take the
test before you get on the flight they
literally dip it
in the cove it's syrup and they put it
they give name
the thing is sarah
seeing how other countries handle covert
compared to here
i'm like holy [ __ ] everyone's so
respectful in every other
country they and especially in turkey
the social distance everywhere you go it
makes you wipe your hands they check
your temperature before you even get
into the taxis and cars
uh they make you wear the mask uh the
airport everyone respects the six feet
when i was at lax nobody ever somebody
breathes out
but in the [ __ ] they'll be breathing
their [ __ ] neck and
everyone on the plane the whole time
they'll be wearing the max and they come
and check they make you wear it
plus they give you masks to wear and
like hand sanitizer so yeah you know
when we
uh this is before the pandemic but when
we had a layover in istanbul they
actually
were like the most thorough airport i've
ever been in
when you take your laptop and they make
you turn it on yeah
damn they're they're so thorough they
even stole their drums no that wasn't
morocco
i'm not gonna i'm not shading turkey
that was morocco
stupid anyway but yeah dude turkey was
so thorough
yeah i was just like oh my god i feel so
safe that raw bread yeah and if
i was like my because i had an ipad and
it was dead so they took this machine
just to check if it was thing and it
wasn't like
like something posing didn't even charge
your ipad for you
hey your battery's dead yeah yeah
your airpods there you go that's nice
they all sanitize it inside with the
q-tips your watch
[Laughter]
who knew a country that was named after
an american bird for thanksgiving would
be
why they were named turkey yep i
wonder if it was named after the bird it
is
they're like eagle no turkey is better
turkey
island bulls named after the chicago
bulls yeah
istanbul because the whole world
revolves around the u.s yup
there's a country called hamburger or
hamburg
oh there is a city city
yeah you know venice italy named it
after venice california yeah
you know that was there's over there i
went to london dad at westminster
just like here oh yeah they had a
westminster in london i was like copied
us
italy copied uh little italy in
louisiana
oh yeah i thought they copied vegas they
caught yeah they copied vegas too eiffel
tower they saw like how are you
the pyramid is that i mean
new york new york copied the biggest
hotel
oh wow i never got rocket blocked
[Laughter]
anyway so we're talking about house
parties here so there was also
uh on the in the news there were these
popular
tick tock creators that also had
their they got planes at all i was with
them in
florida oh yeah well you know these
people
yeah they're at my house too but um you
know these specific guys
oh [ __ ] is it i don't want to say their
names don't say that well she's going to
say their names
um they're very nice these guys
bryce holland yeah you do know them who
so what about them are they twins no so
who's bryce and who's the other one
i think the one on the left is bryce
yeah yeah the guy on the left
yeah what about them they're nice okay
cool
sick cool kids yeah cool
yeah so yeah bryce just social media
people they're just like
the thing of the new wave of social
media that's exactly them
that's cool this article explains them
and all of them
okay got it so what's happening you read
this article no whatever's going to say
it's gonna probably portray nice
yeah so they they kept having the
parties that the fact that they just
kept having parties
no one's wearing masks or social
distancing they have
they had massive crowds in their home
and there were also renting homes and
then throwing parties and so
airbnb parties
so the mayor he got wind of this and
especially in the hollywood hills
there's been a lot of
like house parties happening and they've
just turned into these like nightclubs
in hollywood hills so that's when he
started announcing like well i am going
to be
cutting power off and like utilities off
of you guys keep going because there's
these warnings
and they keep going so you got what
about the celebrities that are innocent
they're like
hey well they're cutting off to specific
locations like that home
that's tight they target the house damn
i don't know they could do that
yeah you didn't i mean they can target
your house to turn it on
they're on the path you're paying your
bills you're paying your bill yeah for
some reason i just keep thinking like
if you don't see it that they shut down
the whole block oh yeah that's true they
do
you think that like if you're at this
house party right and then all the
lights turn off it's like
true i was yeah to them like they could
totally go around this yeah they just
turn on their phone they're like
but the way that it might deter people
from going out is if there's no power
in this heat oh yeah yeah yeah and maybe
people won't be
they probably haven't partying
they just gotta bring battery-powered
things damn
charge your car plus they they
film when they're like oh the mayor shut
it down that's how crazy this party is
it helps them yeah yeah because even one
of the paul
the the jay paul jake i don't know the
one that's the most annoying one
he's the one that was getting in trouble
for throwing like
huge ass parties during this pandemic
their parties look fun though i saw a
clip where
like people are just hanging off like
this tractor thing
they're just like lifting people up and
like it was like a roller coaster ride
oh [ __ ] that looks crazy you know last
time dropping off into the pool and
stuff
when we did the news about them and we
didn't know the real reason why the fbi
was
looking after them oh yeah it it's
involving
a sex trafficking ring so like their
parties
had uh girls getting drugged up and like
accusations and all this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] so
and then his friend
was is a convicted pimp yeah so he was
running
a prostitution ring and things like that
so
there's just all this investigation
going on because last time we didn't say
that on the news
yes we didn't know yeah so like i think
what you saw casey is like the the party
it looks so wild right so all of us are
just like oh i want to be at one of
those parties yeah
and you know guys and girls are thinking
that right and then like
girls get invited and then like things
are going down
allegedly right so that's being
investigated because i was like what the
[ __ ] is going on we didn't really like
know at that time and then it they were
saying that it was connected to
uh them breaking into a mall during like
looting or whatever like that's not
enough
for the fbi yeah yeah cause i was like
that's pretty overkill
for like the national guard the black
team was there
like i mean it looked like some legit it
looks like some military [ __ ]
[ __ ] was that confirmed so like that it
was sex trafficking
yeah no that is the invest that's what
the investigation is really about
but there's no uh clear like
what they're getting charged for or
anything yet yeah because initially
that's an investigation the reports were
saying that authorities were saying that
it was connected to arizona
but now
yeah so that's that's the crazy part man
i don't know man like these parties
i mean you think about it right like
let's say this happened to me a lot too
where like
you would crack like some random people
will crash or like
when you have even 40 guests
there's a friend of a friend you don't
even know who the [ __ ] is and they
like invited them and you they're just
like hey what's up this is my friend
or whatever you're like that's cool but
you don't know who the [ __ ] is
i've knocked somebody out at parties at
my friend's house
or like or like fought because i was
like this guy's disrespecting my
friend's
house or whatever but like a lot of it
is like you don't know like when you're
when you're just having these
freaking house parties like not everyone
knows each other well i mean i think
that's one one perspective right but
then you also have the fact that we're
in a pandemic
and that there's this freaking virus
being spread between people and we
should not be gathering
with that many people in such close
quarters it's just like
come on man we know that you're this
really young
like you think you're gonna live forever
kind of person because
those are the people that are going to
these parties it is crazy though that
like they put
the pressure on them which i get because
especially in california there are like
famous people
but this is happening 10 times worse
than every other state everyone's back
to normal everyone's partying and
everything but because of california's
lockdown which again we should i feel
like we should be on lockdown
um but like you look at florida it's way
worse than these parts and that happened
months ago at the peak of our lockdown
during spring break them now it's like
crazy that you see like
my friends that are like posting from
there and it looks like nothing has ever
happened
i think the difference is for them
they're like we're all gonna say
we don't give a [ __ ] right and i'm cool
but then over here it's like
we all really do care and then there's a
couple of people that are going against
the grain i think that's right
yeah and the local authorities too
dictate like how they react too because
then i guess in florida they don't
like to talk everyone don't give a [ __ ]
i guess well the cops don't care here
until they get pressured from like being
like hey you have to do something
because i'm like that's true
my friend's gym's open like the cops are
coming like we don't give a [ __ ]
that's true you know and then like um
because they're like we we hate this
because we're getting
um um everyone's hours are just a
punishment though it's like you know
like let's say uh
you know i'm taking talk famous so i
decided to host a giant party in the
hollywood hills
right and i bring like 40 plus at least
50 people six people
endanger people am i fine is what
they're gonna turn off the electricity
yeah are there any like that's my
punishment or you you have like
assembly big assembly rules or whatever
yeah i mean we just tried to deter them
one of those just like if you get caught
doing that it's like uh yeah it's just
it's like a hundred thousand dollar fine
nothing big
just a you know just a [ __ ] financial
find that's gonna help pay for stuff
that's going on during this time that'd
be helpful maybe that could go to this
corona research and they could find a
damn carol right you know what i mean
it's like it's like yo if you want a
party just part just
pay and ridiculous tax is gonna actually
progress us as a community
what if we grab them have them go fight
our fires right now mm-hmm oh yeah
or just throw them in the fire oh my
hairspray
headset's on fire because if there's no
like actual punishment and it's like i'm
not gonna
they're gonna [ __ ] party next week
they are issuing citations and stuff
uh start opening up again and open up
outdoors
uh like seating they had to pay extra to
do that
they had to pay uh fines and like uh uh
legal things to open up outside
yeah just because of this whole virus
thing so they're paying
stuff to do it properly and like safely
i'm sure there's a way they can like
get an outdoor event yeah meanwhile we
got what gyms dance studios out here
that are just like they're doing a
bottom
bracket outdoor concerts right now where
they're like having these like
pens like these little like bullpens per
group yeah and then they're like
distance it's like okay well
yeah you're at a concert yes there's a
[ __ ] ton of people but at least they're
distanced yeah that's like not that bad
yeah it's weird where they and it's
outdoors
where they do allow because then like if
they are gonna open up stuff slowly
like gyms is probably a safer place to
be than a lot of other places that they
open up
like completely why it's just like in
terms of how far you are from people how
much you have to like be in the
environment and how much like
you're actually working they're actually
not that close to each other yeah is it
but is it like the touching of the
equipment no but we're all everyone so
like at least at our gym
uh everyone gets handed disinfected in
the towel when they come in
and our gym culture like everyone's
pretty like follow
what the whole group wants and all of
our stations are already
eight feet apart so it didn't matter
that the six feet social distance and
all their equipment are already eight
feet apart that's good
[Music]